hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm a giant idiot because look it
was right here
the guy was freaking pointing at it how
did I overlook that I haven't I'm
recording this all in series right so
you guys probably saw that and I am the
biggest giganticus loser in all of
loserdom I mean what oh I had eight
seconds huh what what Oh Cornell
isn't that the explosive thingy
heating hog whoops
okey-dokey anyway that was weird
suddenly picking up the key makes a
whole room and okay
finally finally I have the key oh my god
progress progress progress pork rest
thank you so much
oh this that chair moved
Oh what kind of world is it's coming to
the chairs are not on my side and the
mannequins are
yeah yeah oh you're already broken yeah
man okay so let's look II look look for
special ID plate items anyway good oh
man I can't believe how big of an idiot
I am
it was right there I'm actually out of
lantern oil faces blotted out I'm out of
lantern oil for the moment hello oh so
little oil I swear oh man but I guess
that's a good thing keeps things dark
and Atmospheric at times does make it a
bit hard to find what you're looking for
but well I mean if you just stand in the
darkness for a bit you'll you'll get
adjusted to it uh oh yeah no down in
them and what are you kids doing in a
circle I don't trust anything I know
it's here I see him coming in the study
before he goes to the end of the hall to
the closed up room no one should go
there but I know he is I just wish I
knew what he's hiding in there ah I
found it but I won't write it down in my
notes you dick where it was but yeah I
was right such a clever boy he is now
it's time to get in that room what all
that work for just a bunch of junk
unless I'm missing something important
of course you are
and the other dish okay so he found a
secret rotor rat which I'm guessing is
is given that there are many bookshelves
is a pulley book
oh oh no oh you didn't argue son of a
[ __ ] oh I got an arm
not here bro
not here at all ah-ah can't see me can't
see me all evasion level 99 ah no that's
a dead body
ah get out of here
you're a douche no one likes you fatten
your ugly get out get out get out
good get your ugly dare you betray me go
over there why Oh what am I doing wrong
my life why has it come to this
can't get me I'm so great everybody tell
me how great I am I'm so great I'm oh
hello wait you're not coming back are
you
[Music]
yeah yeah get out of here get out of
here bro
what are you doing what's going on oh I
just have to work with him being in the
same room as me okay fine I'll do it do
it your way do it live
ah no don't be this wheel okay I didn't
I was looking around the room I didn't
see any pulley but whew
what do I do I just get out of here
maybe I'm over there
yeah that's right he's just stupid
he's over there now oh all right you
want to go you want to go blah blah blah
blogger for blood end brother ah yeah
chair finally works okay 300 miss me by
a mile
okay anyway how to deal with that
squealing in my ears
cuz that's perfectly normal I gotta find
like I know there's got to be like a
full book that opens up the brick wall
over there it's not up here
miss me dick ah don't hit me bro
yo hit me bro you were closer than I
thought oh god get away oh you so ugly
okay now I'm over here now are you gonna
do nothing
oh hello don't do nothing oh go block by
the heaven table Oh dance let's dance
dance dance Eid and all now I'm over
here now yeah get down with it take that
thing get over here yeah oh yeah
Oh get the dance you dance make me look
get down tonight
I'll miss me miss me down tonight oh
yeah you're a dick oh okay anyway so
what do I do about this thing kind of a
problem because I can't really look
while you're here
alright I'm gonna I'm gonna trust you on
this one I'm gonna get close and don't
kill me and then just go away okay ready
here we go I thought who is working for
a second okay here we go ha okay I'm
hoping that when I die you'll go away
it's kinda cheating but not really or
maybe if I hit actually hid without
provoking and me probably would have
gone away a long time okay here we go
[Music]
either way totally legitimate learn to
play noobs
now I'm really looking for the Pulido
holy book holy book in the corner no
never
secret lever switch button oh this is
gonna take me forever
oh okay so nothing there I got very
limited amounts of oil wait
what is this oh oh ah yeah I missed
something opening I wondered what it is
I could have gotten that with the
monster in there oh my god
to the left maggot that was a very
obscure what what what oh that's stupid
that's stupid did it like is it on a
timer
do I get like run for it probably
probably
Oh what huh what oh you faked me out
okay whatever it don't I got it Oh
progress progress yeah more bookshelves
my favorite chair
what happened - what happened in there
yeah here bed oh I see you anyway get
out of here yeah you came at me came
right for me Oh what
wha-ha-ha-ha-ha what the heck oh my god
that's that's that's cool hello a get
down think oh yeah whoops oh yeah there
we go
yeah no stay open please today stay okay
[Music]
we were having fun while this go no fun
time
why go no fun
oh I hate these tunnels okay coos Oh
dead guy oh oh I just realized how dark
it was my room
Oh what's going on what's going on
what's the deal what's going on together
way dead guy please move
[Music]
why are there never any candles for me
to light all their iron plug two key and
there is a trick to the electro waves
that no one knows about it's meant to
keep strangers trapped even if they find
all the keys for it if you put all the
keys in each terminal the waves will
switch to a non-lethal way that looks
exactly the same but only the master and
I know know about this it's such a good
trick I'll just write this diabolically
on this dirty note it's such a good
trick I should have read that note
differently I hear I hear guy I hear mr.
wheezy oh hi
oh hi oh oh okay um so I got the key
sleeping area in the archives okay I
know where I'm headed now okay I got to
go back I know I got a key for the other
door in that the weird electro room
I still don't like this in fact I'd like
it even less now
oh my god oh man for something that did
absolutely nothing how did I miss these
chests man for something that did
absolutely nothing that was terrifying I
didn't like that at all these don't even
open well find that me that way I'm out
of here
screw this and screw you and screw your
face not the maker of this month cause
he's great but screw them someone said
that the Justin monsters were kind of
creepier and I you know it they're
creepy in a different way they actually
they actually say some stuff like they
came in and these just even if you
haven't seen it I have a playthrough of
it didn't look through my play list I
mean it's actually getting the points
funny because I've got over 400 videos
where people will talk to me and they'll
ask me hey can you play this
can you play dead space can you play
dead space - can you play amnesia just
see now I go oh I've already played them
look through my playlist I've got over
400 videos of great content if you like
these videos you'll love all 400 of my
other ones so let's pick a series
they're all they're all really fun and
maybe I do say so myself I wasn't bad in
any of them I'm so great everybody come
see how good I look all right I gotta go
back to
someplace oh yeah through the portal I
think I got it but before I do that I
have to cut it here thank you everybody
so much for watching as always I
appreciate every single one of you and
as always again I will see you in the
next part bye-bye